THE HASHTAKEOFF.
HE IS NOT GETTING HIS WAY.
AGAIN!
>> Kelenna:IT.
WIGGINS AT THE HORN, AND IT'SRE.
KEVIN:BOB:UT
THERE, TWO DEFENDERS.
WING N
THE RIM AND POST IT.
WE GOT A UNBELIEVABLY QUICK
DIME?
GO STRAIGHT UP AND WATCH IN SCR.
>> Bob:: IN
BETWEEN ANDREW WIGGINS, THE
>> THAT'S WHAT HE DOES.
BY CURRY.
THIS IS JUST -- THAT IS A CLEVEI
.
STEPH CURRY IS JUST SPECIAL.S A.
THE WARRIORS HAVN ISTIATED THE
CONTACT.
THIS IS GOING TO GO AGAINST
POOL.INDIAN RID OF IT QUICKLY AD
GAME.
THREE-POINT SHOOTING TEAM.
THE LAW OF AVERAGES. UP SHAMET.
CLEARED IT PIECE OF
>> Bob: DRAYMOND.
LEANINGWIGGINS ARE REALLY
>> Bob: SIAKAM ON HIS
LEADING SCORER EVER FROM CANADA.
AGO.
>> Bob: 0 FOR 6.
ANDREW IT.
JUSTWIGGINS QUICK TO BODY
HOW HE ELEVATES, BOOM, HANGER A.
THAT WAS ABIG DEFICIT.
>> ON BYTATE HERE.
>> Grant: BECAUSE GOLDEN STATE
TO THE RIM.
>> Brian: UP TOP, OH, IT A LOT S
WHATME.
>> Mike: JUMP BALL.
WI